from the telegraph oil cartel joins
forces with Russia to cut supplies
congratulations ladies and gentlemen
because of the war in Ukraine a gentle
gentleman yes because of the war in
Ukraine that we are involved in
OPEC Saudi Arabia are joining with
Russia cutting production cranking up
prices so that Russia can keep selling
at a premium rate to China and then sell
it back to us so we are getting screwed
and funding this war
your costs are going to go up your
standard of living is going to go down
and it's because Joe Biden is a corrupt
piece of trash who keeps funneling our
money to Ukraine why do we why should I
care about Ukraine because because
Vladimir Putin's charging too much for
natural gas into Europe well too bad you
build your pipeline like they did the
Baltic pipe fine blowing up someone
else's pipeline expanding your military
Alliance all of this was pushing towards
War now Putin invaded Ukraine bad thing
I get it but I'm not going to sit here
and say the U.S should sacrifice its
people so that Ukraine can have so that
we can deal with their problem I just
here you go thanks Joe Biden let's see
if this this impacts the midterms well
if you remember a couple months ago Joe
Biden had a very uh publicized trip to
Saudi Arabia where he was going to go to
Saudi Arabia and make sure that they
produce more energy and oil from the
world since of course it's very green to
stop domestic energy exploration and
production and of course depend on Saudi
Arabia and the Henry Kissinger supported
Petro dollar which again absolutely
mind-boggling but if you remember from
that trip he was like I'm gonna go there
I'm gonna make sure we have a ton of
energy they're going to be pumping in
out of the ground and and there was even
a press release from the White House
saying this this trip was successful and
then the Saudi Arabians came out said no
it wasn't we're not going to be pumping
oil we're not doing that and now this is
on the heels of that meeting of Joe
Biden going down to Saudi Arabia and
essentially I do think the OPEC
countries the oil producing countries
are looking out for themselves because
they see this as an opportunity they
will be enriching themselves and I do
see other individuals that are going to
of course be also benefiting from an
energy crisis which is already here and
it's only going to get worse with this
latest news this to me is a longer part
of the agenda of the great reset which
is deliberately denying people energy to
stop human progress and enslave them we
just got a good Super Chat from just
political makes a good point nothing
will stop a midterm election faster than
emergency wartime powers
if Russia were a month out what if the
October surprise is that Putin drops a
nuke and they suspend elections what do
you mean Putin that's right so let's put
that in quotes because we don't know
yeah what happens
or something crazy like any kind of
conventional and they suspend election
saying we can't so it's an emergency and
the country's got to mobilize
that's what we are man he got a third
term during wartime they let him stay I
don't put anything past these people but
I think we also have to understand that
the infrastructure is still there that
allows for elections to be gamed I don't
think that we should have voting systems
in other words machines that are plugged
into anything that can be accessed by a
router that do fractional voting I don't
think we should have mail and voting I I
think the issue is Ian points out all
the time is the closed Source nature of
the machines but yeah because if the
code is private I really don't want to
segue the conversation off of what we
were talking about because my concern is
will there be a nuclear strike is there
going to be severe economic damage from
say uh oil prices skyrocketing what do
we see like nine bucks already in
California again like eight eight fifty
or something like that will that result
in some kind of emergency wartime powers
or the inverse says they can't shut the
election down it would destroy the
country gas prices are so high Democrats
get swept out of office I was going to
say to you okay Stacy Abrams but that's
beyond the point from the conversation
here but anyway it this will be
impacting the average American but more
significantly the people who don't have
money the people who are the poorest in
our country will now have a harder time
making ends meet paying for gas for your
car paying for heat this winter will
become more difficult not just for the
people in the United States but
specifically other people outside of the
United States who don't have it as as
lucky as we do people in Europe are
absolutely dealing with a huge energy
crisis where many businesses are already
shutting down their doors because they
can't find a way to pay for the energy
bill that's that's crazy your life
savings are going towards heating your
home right now in Europe and this is how
you're spending your money when of
course a lot of this is orchestrated by
Bad Decisions by politicians and Central
controllers that are artificially hiking
up the price of energy for their own
personal benefit because they know once
they create artificial scarcity they're
able to do what they want with the human
population and with the decline of
energy it also brings on the decline of
the food production it brings on the
decline of humanity
I think that you need an October
surprise right so you're talking about
all these price increases I think that
this is part of what the sustainability
movement really is and what
sustainability really means is your
standard of living is going to plummet
so this is further hurting anything
that's remnant of the middle class
they're lying about how much inflation
has gone on obviously it's more than
eight point whatever percent and if you
continue these Trends gradually you got
the country even further and you really
go into this Global idea set of scarcity
and we need a new system of control and
that's where you have your social credit
score that's where you have your carbon
credit system even the world economic
Forum I know we mentioned Iran they have
their world food program that they plan
on running through the blockchain they
have a whole little bit wow about
running uh refugee camps via blockchain
technology you guys seen uh you remember
Viva Vendetta when Natalie Portman is
eating the toast and she's like is this
real butter like I haven't had this I
was a kid that's what they want for you
and your kids your kids are going to
wake up in the morning and they're
you're going to be laying next to them
in your pod they're going to open the
pod and they're going to be you know
outside surrounded by a whole bunch of
other pods and then the robot's gonna
drive by and hand your child a bowl of
crickets with what with floating in
water and the kid's gonna be spooning it
and that's breakfast cereal and then the
robot says and remember if you follow
all the rules and bend the knee you
might get a small piece of beef this
week
it true but I think it will be too
dangerous to give kids spoons because
you could use them as weapons so they'll
probably have them plastic
semi-conscious in a floating tank of
biological
harvesting their heat yeah you're locked
in the Pod and the tube just goes into
your mouth The Crickets just get poured
if you're lucky otherwise it's going in
the other other Southern
um I don't know why they wouldn't shoot
Cricket up your ass have you started to
liquefy them first uh have you studied
absorption what do you think they that
the overall idea of the transhumanist
desire for the human population is like
I I think that they want us in back to
tanks like in Star Trek or in Star Wars
where Luke has his hand cut off but
they're like floating him in that tank
but it's like regenerating his body
slowly but something that's
piezoelectric and can wear your body
just the heat vibrates
we really jumped overboard from and only
we don't have to stay on this topic yeah
nice digression there do you think they
want like people docile and tanks do you
think they want them working at jobs
what do you it's two different things
right so the transhumans agenda for
those that can afford it is you're going
to be able to remain in your biological
body and the advancements will allow you
to at least double your lifespan a lot
of these things people think that you
know Jared Kushner went on television
two weeks ago and said my generation is
either going to be the first to live
forever or the last to die now Jared
Kushner has billions of dollars to spend
on that the vast majority of us don't
the same people that are investing in
that technology via things like Calico
which is run by Kurzweil in his alphabet
or Google's company on immortality then
you have the people that want you to
merge with the machines and this is kind
of the digital human or mind clone
aspect of it so at one aspect the very
rich believe that they're going to be
able to stay in their biological body
but then they're going to try to
acclimate the rest of us to accept
things like neuralink human brain
interfaces and Beyond to the point where
they get the populace to believe that
they can actually upload their
Consciousness into a digital hellscape
in my opinion but this metaverse so
you're going to be spending so much time
in the metaverse anyway before the human
brain interfaces you're going to be
acclimated to these things and you're
going to hate reality especially if you
can't eat steak anymore and you can't
have a burger and you can't travel
because you can't afford your gas in
your car yeah like that dude in The
Matrix remember he's eating the steak
and he's like I don't care well first
before they do that they need to put the
human population on their knees and I do
believe this artificial scarcity this
energy crisis to bring him back to the
topic that we were discussing here is
the first step out of many steps in
order to make the general population
acquiesce by robbing people of their
wealth and the ability to survive
therefore they will become dependent on
the central controllers on big Tech
social media companies and these
billionaires eugenicists and and other
crazy people who do believe that they
will be living forever as you mentioned
from that comment by Jared Kushner who
who openly said hey I'm taking care of
my body I'm going to be living forever
he said that pretty confidently and
that's something that of course people
should be thinking about the larger
ramifications of because if we have
Elites that are living forever what's
that what is everyone else going to be
living to and how are they going to be
controlled and stopped from living from
ever and these people are essentially
creating a situation where they're going
to be the next gods and they're making
themselves Gods through this fourth
Industrial Revolution with the
technological progression that we have
been making that is extremely dangerous
and has a lot of implications that we
haven't even thought about so are you
saying the Democrats are going to lose
it doesn't matter because the the
billionaire Bankers will bankroll and
finance both of them and then screw
everyone else over thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there